well i'm joined now by the sun's
robotographer arthur edwards and royal
editor of vanity fair katie nicholl
along with playwright novelist uh bonnie
greer well welcome to all of you uh
arthur great to have you here i feel
like in platinum jubilee wheat this is
like it's like having almost like having
the queen paint me a visit so welcome
thanks dude um you've written a piece
about megan harry i'm going to come to
the moment i want to start though by
talking about this remarkable bbc
documentary last night because i
honestly think it was the best royal
documentary i've ever watched and me too
i thought it was fantastic and the
and the the king i mean the way he was
playing with his grandchildren i mean
that man was always considered like to
be a stutterer and a very you know
didn't want the job but my god he came
across as a fantastic and of course the
duke of edinburgh you know absolutely
the slide on the royal yacht with the
kids i mean it was unbelievable and the
queen shot a lot of that footage itself
well that was a great thing wasn't it
katie was that this footage was raw
footage taken by the royals of
themselves these were family home videos
which we've never really seen you have
and you've got to really see them as a
family i think it dispelled so many of
the myths about the queen actually she's
so often seen certainly in those early
days of a mother who was quite aloof
well she she was full of love for her
children there was nothing staged for
the cameras and it was wonderful to see
her and and the young princess margaret
interacting and playing and obviously i
love margaret and the queen together
interacting even when they were very
young and then teenagers and then a bit
later really because they have a very
close sort of quite mischievous
relationship with each other right yeah
and i think you you've got to see that
dynamic of what they called we four the
queen mother and the king and these two
young daughters enjoying the most
wonderful life but i think you're right
about it being the best royal
documentary i mean people might remember
elizabeth r and the royal family
probably not i know some of these people
the power of this was the simplicity it
was of the home footage and then the
queen now
the racing back over her own life and
and then the pictures of charles and
anne is talking about amazing and i mean
i work a lot with prince charles and now
i think about him like that you know and
he was just brilliant it was a great
moment when they played a clip about her
view of the platinum jubilee let's
listen to this
i don't know that anyone had invented
the term platinum for a 70th anniversary
when i was born
you won't expect it to be around that
long
typically
bonnie greer before we get into probably
slightly more incendiary territory with
the royals let's talk about the queen
for a moment because i i don't really
care whether you're pro monarchy
anti-monarchy in the world you cannot
but have respect for this woman who for
70 years has been on the throne
barely put a foot wrong in that entire
time and does exemplify the very things
she talked about when she was 21 duty
and service
well you know believe it or not and good
evening everybody believe it or not
my family was royalist my my mother
certainly was
so i grew up with enormous respect for
her and if you you know what you may not
have noticed no one said it the queen's
changed her accent she didn't talk the
way she was a child she's got less she's
changed
exactly that's my point but my next
point is that chimes have changed and we
need to change too because she certainly
has well i think that's a very good
point and arthur i think the whole
future of the monarchy when the queen
sadly the day comes when she's
eventually not with us is it going to be
a very very crucial one not just very
difficult just for britain but for the
world years indeed and uh prince charles
got a tough job in fact to uh to keep it
on two bit online and going and of
course you know many of the countries uh
that where the queen is head of state
will will pull out you know i mean i
think certainly australia will maybe new
zealand perhaps canada but it's going to
be a change and but the principals will
cope with that he said when we left
barbados last year when they gave up the
queen he said well it's what they want
um and that's fair enough so there will
be changes but uh and prince of wales is
already thinking about that well he's i
think he'll be a much better king than
some people seem to i think so too he's
a he's a lovely man he's a ways and of
course he'd never he's tireless and if
you think of very much piers he's a
visionary you know when he was 25 years
ago talking about organic food and
people calling crazy and there every
store you go to now has got organic food
and complementary medicine and everybody
takes some sort of confidential medicine
and uh and so you know he's a visionary
and i followed him and when i started
doing this job i didn't care less about
what i was doing just get pictures of
anything but slowly listening to him the
way where he's presented his speeches
and where he asked the
people in brazil and malaysia not to rip
up the rainforest and and almost and and
you know the plastic in the sea fights
for that he does and he's been ahead of
his time on a number of these things
katie
we're going to see on the balcony on
thursday morning the trooping the color
a streamlined royal lineup you're not
gonna have harry and megan or andrew or
the others who've been into dodgy
territory in the last few years you're
gonna have the main players yep the
queen and you have charles and camilla
and then you have kate and william and
that is the that's the line of
succession right there but you don't
forget you're going to have the duke of
kent the gloucesters the west extension
princess and yep
it's really about the main event it is
but it's interesting piers because when
you think back to the diamond and um
you'll remember this as well it it was
very much about the streamlined royal
family it was just the queen the
cambridges
charles and camilla so i think this is
very important to the queen that she is
having an opportunity to thank those
that those that she calls my substitutes
the people who have stood in well the
ones you've actually done the hard grasp
the ones that the workers if you count
the number of duties these are the ones
who put the yards in two who won't be on
the balcony but are coming in are megan
and harry
you've written a pretty
robust and direct letter to them in
tonight's son in which you basically
plead with them not to try and steal the
limelight from the queen yeah because if
they publish a picture when the queen
meets lilybet that will wipe everything
else out you know that's that that's
what i'm thinking you know ivana's
talking to the editor tonight and saying
that that picture will just
scream in and everything the queens are
trying to achieve with this
you know doing her very best to make
appearances and
it would just go to pieces and i just
hope she doesn't turn up with a
photographer to do that and uh put it
out and i don't think the queen would
allow it anyway how damaging have they
been those two with their antics i mean
i have a few that people know but what
do you think well the oprah winfrey
interview was the thing that turned me
off them immediately because some of the
lies in that that were told some of the
untruths and misleading statements
certainly about archie's color arches
skin you know i mean when that remark
was made there wasn't even engaged it
wasn't even talking about him in a child
but the way it came across in the
interview it looked like it had been
discussed while she was pregnant but of
course it wasn't and then talking to
people of mixed race
they say to me they discuss if they were
having a baby with the color or if they
a chinese couple i know a lady married
to a chinese lady they they discuss it
without my eyes and i think it all
depends on the context we've never been
told in context bonnie i know that
you're a supporter of megan and harry my
views are well known arthur shares those
views about this i i felt from that
interview onwards they've been on a very
strange journey where for a couple that
left the country for privacy they've
never stopped doing
media stuff for a couple who
trash the monarchy in the institution
they keep using their royal titles to
commercially benefit themselves to the
tune of tens of millions of dollars so
i'm pretty cynical about what they've
done uh you do you think i'm wrong
well you know no you're not wrong to be
if you want to be cynical but i think
what we're forgetting here is that this
family is probably one of the most
resilient
uh pr exercises of at least the 20th
century remember they pulled off one of
the biggest brand coups of the 20th
century by changing their name from a
german name to the name of their their
residence they also uh pulled off
another coup when um uh
around the funeral the princes of wales
i mean they've been changing all the
time while giving people the illusion
that they haven't i mean they're
absolutely brilliant and this will be
handled too i mean i don't know why
people are freaking out so much about
this uh this is this family exists and
survives because it can't adapt and it's
too bad that the people who support them
don't know how to do that themselves
yeah i mean i think after
if you go back over your time covering
the rules four decades there have been a
lot of big royal scandals i mean we we
feel like because of social media the
megan and harry antics and prince andrew
and son have been really big but there
have been as we know from that
documentary last night the abdication of
a king over a love affair probably
dwarfs any of this stuff that's right
and they went on to live in america but
they never dumped on the royal family
not once they
i hate to say this with bonnie here but
you know we are with american women now
two for two yeah right we've had two of
them come here hang on let me say
something no they didn't come they they
got married
to into the royal family and and it's
true
that family edward i mean sorry the the
duke of windsor and the duchess of
windsor
cashed in it is not even in comparison
to what megan and harry are doing well
making was not about cash they were paid
they were paid to go to nightclubs they
had all kinds of things
people that what they never did after
say which is true they never attacked
the royal family in public and i would
have no problem i've got no problem with
megan and harry if megan and harry gave
up their titles and just lived off being
megan and harry celebrities
you're forgetting one thing
this guy gave up
the crown yeah he didn't have that that
was the cool day at the coolest theater
right there so he already attacked the
royal family okay that was done and
probably done for all time okay okay you
have to do anything
making good points and i don't disagree
thank you katie i mean this goes back to
my point to arthur we have gone through
you know centuries of royal scandal i
mean imagine this social media being
around with henry viii
i'm beheading his wife i mean it's all
relative you know it's all relative but
i think it's the way the queen has
weathered these storms i mean look at
the death of diana and the way that
almost you know saw the tide really
nearly turn against the queen she
reigned that back in i i spoke to
someone for my new book who said to me
excellent by the way the new royals very
good read this was this was so important
he said to me the queen has the most
remarkable capacity for
for forgiveness and i think that's what
you're going to see with the because she
wants this tube yeah her family
come in i've met the queen a couple of
times and i'll tell you one one occasion
i met her which i thought was
extraordinary this was the reopening of
windsor castle okay this place had
burned down there were people in there
smoking now that was my house i would
have said hold it
cut it out
my place has already burned down you
people are lighting up cigarettes that
was when we were allowed people were
allowed to do that she walks in
she walks around you know you can't talk
to her you have to be taken over to her
and then she danes to speak
people walking through people's smoke
everything cool as a cucumber i wouldn't
worry about her at all i mean nothing
but nothing flusters the queen certainly
not in public
i wanted to show you a picture it's a
stonehenge which they lit up with eight
pictures images beamed onto stonehenge
as a queen through the years i thought
this was a wonderful idea didn't you i
do i do too but i've had a print made
today one of my favorite pictures of the
queen i'm going to put up in my window
of my house tonight you know i'm very
excited about it yeah everywhere you
know it's uh what's your favorite memory
of the queen personally oh personally
well when she gave me my uh mbe when she
uh she said i can't believe i'm giving
you this she said did she give it to me
and uh and she's no longer been coming
down here to photograph me i said then
it was 20 years ago i said 27 years
ma'am
she said oh let's have our picture taken
together oh that was really amazing yeah
and that really was moving i've never
forgotten that and yeah
and funny as i walked away prince andrew
came up to me said oh what did you get i
said nbe he said what does that stand
for i said much bigger expenses
it's a privilege to have you you're one
of the all-time great world
photographers and you still do it and i
won't ask you how old you are but i know
and it's amazing the energy and drive
you still have for your your craft thank
god
it's a nice job a nice people i work
with lovely people so royal tours are
always the most fun with arthur of
course everything's brilliant
everything's more fun with arthur katie
thank you very much the new royals is
out now queen elizabeth legacy in
november
in november coming out you got it first
in november first early copy okay cool
and bonnie greer thank you very much
indeed that was quite civilized for us i
thought
[Laughter]
no comment from bonnie she's not she's
not agreeing or otherwise no i i i no it
was civilized because at the end of the
day
they're gonna come anyway so that's that
you know i mean that's that and it'll
all be over
bonnie great to see you come back thank
you pierce thank you take care of
yourself